صعدت إلى الخارج ، وكانت هناك كلاب حمراء وطاولات عامية متضخمة.
العقبات الرسمية أصغر
[صفق]
أوه ، من فضلك توقف عند الفيلم السابق الذي قدمته اللجنة الدائمة للمكتب السياسي للتسلسل الأخير لحزب العمال المدعو.
الرفيق الحار والرمز العسكري لـ Han Young-ae هو Kang Dong-jin المصغر
أوه جو يونغ ، كبير أمناء كفاءة الوقود في سوق التسمم الكلي ، كيونغان دونغ ز
أحلم بامتلاك سيارة في شيان ، الفرع المركزي للمدينة ، بشعر طويل
[موسيقى]
واضح الاهتزاز ز الألغام أحادية الفعل الجوهرية
جميع البنائين لديهم نفس الحب والإيمان في الاضطرابات الكهربائية القلبية
احتفظ
مع اختراق الروح الهجومية والسلاح في دقيقة واحدة ، تأسيس الحزب ، هذه الأيام ، أكثر
بحلول عام 2025
في مدينة Zhengyang ، ما بين 10000 وحدة في السنة ، باستثناء بيت الزعتر
آه نعم آه آه
[صفق]
أمام هذا ، أنا غاضب بعد محاضرة Jang Gwa-han الخاصة التي تقول إنه مسموح لي بالمواعدة.
في نافذة الحفل ، كان العمال يتدربون عندما خسر جميع المسؤولين الحكوميين ، بعد كثيرين
مثال على إطار قديم مزود بملاحظة مرجعية مصطنعة مع الهبوط
لا يزال Kim Jong-eun حفلة محترمة
لم يفِ بالوعد
2.1 رماد فرن صهر إيرل ، خزانات هزيلة ضعيفة جدًا ، تسلي حماس الشركات
عليك ان تعطي
آه
5 ـ حماية الوزن بعد أخذ يده العارية
الهجرة 2001 لحزب أوري ، ختم إيديولوجية وانغ كيونغ المحطمة
كان Taebong رائعًا.